They want you to buy in her life.
My favorite example of this ridiculous,
which is Nascar.
Here's this,
you know,
it's,
it's somewhat legitimate because here's
actual,
an actual sport behind this brand.
There's actually a product that people
can get.
It's new.
It's,
it's,
it's got a lot of different angles to
it,
but NASCAR sales romance novels and ask
ourselves packaged meats.
Nascar is this massive lifestyle brand
that wants to find all kinds of touch
points to draw you further into the
NASCAR lifestyle.
Um,
so from a consumer perspective,
uh,
you know,
what brands do you like?
How are they drawing you in so that you
spend more of your money with them?
Is it apple,
you know,
would you,
would you buy an apple product even if
it wasn't as good as something else?
Is it a certain brand of clothing?
I'm Thomas Pink makes,
makes great shirts,
but they also spray a certain linen
scent into every one of their stores.
Why?
Why not just let the linen smell like
linen?
I mean,
there's,
there's certain marketing tactics these
brands use to try and generate a feel
sensory feel of psychological feel,
a belonging and community and ritual and
that that's,
that that's for the consumer.
It's that kind of sense of community
that,
that brands are after with lifestyle I'm
pitches.
Would that feel of being part of a
community around a brand.
Apple is another good example.
Nascar,
I mean these,
these,
these communities that bubble up around
popular brands and they tried to capture
that and then
sell,
sell you more products.
BMW,
Yoga,
wear
for clothing or Cheetos,
lip balm.
But,
but you know,
this,
this lifestyle stuff,
it does begin to.
It's corrosive to the,
to the sense of where our communities
are formed.
Are Our communities formed around brands
like apple now and Nascar?
Yes,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
You should.
They,
should,
they are,
they have,
they kind of become more virtual and
more online and brands are set up to
kind of put tolls around those
experiences.
And also,
you know,
also true.
I think,
um,
the,
the damage to how we relate together as
people and how we form relationships.
And think of ourselves even in terms of
our identity and our self esteem or
aspirations.
It is largely influenced by marketing.
Now more important than ever.